ce à quoi le sperme
comment tu as moi ça va merci de
demander pourquoi tu veux savoir ça on
va lister super précieux j'ai vraiment
besoin d'argent pour avoir le mien on
raconte beaucoup de choses sur le sperme
alors parfois parce que ça arrange les
gens mais on va en reparler parfois
juste parce que ça fascine un liquide
capables de créer la vie pas tout seul
je le rappelle un liquide qu'on peut
produire sur commande
à condition d'être équipé et qui donne
du plaisir quand on le fait une espèce
de délire presque mystique autour du
sperme
du coup ça me paraît important de
remettre un peu les choses à leur place
et de regarder ça d'un peu plus près
façon de parler un pour voir ce qui a
vraiment dedans et oui je sais
exactement à quoi m'attendre avec cette
vidéo
tant pis pour la démo native de rien bon
déjà le sperme c'est pas juste un fluide
corporel
c'est plusieurs fluides corporels c'est
pour ça que c'est pas toujours très
homogène donc oui le sperme c'est un
cocktail et comme vous êtes sympas je
vais vous donner l'heure
on est tous contre tous
pour réaliser la recette du sperme vous
aurez besoin du matériel suivre 1ère
12h25 heure du sopalin et surtout pas de
glaçons c'est un cocktail qui donne le
meilleur de lui même à température
ambiante
passons aux ingrédients maintenant il
vous faut 3,25 millilitres de liquide
séminal 1 millilitre de sécrétions
prostatique 0.5 médite de sécrétions et
pidy lhimer 0,2 mille litres de liquide
prégent accusatoire 0,05 millilitres de
spermatozoïdes verser l'ensemble des
ingrédients dans le shaker saisissez le
tchèque heures dans une main et le
sopalin dans l'autre secouer
vigoureusement jusqu'à ce que ce soit
prêt
et voilà c'est prêt vous avez préparé
l'équivalent d'un évacue la moyens c'est
à dire environ 5000 hélico sperme soit
le contenu d'une cuillère à café il est
possible qu'il y ait quelques grumeaux
ne vous inquiétez pas ça n'est pas grave
et ça ne remet pas en cause la qualité
du cocktail ça apporte même un peu de
texture ça donne un côté de la baltique
au revoir on est tous
c'est vrai pour les grues moment
vraiment fait rien du tout parfois le
sperme est un peu plus visqueux donc ça
donne cette apparence mais ça change
rien à sa qualité donc pas de souci bon
donc maintenant vous savez ce qu'il ya
dans le cocktail mais on va faire un
petit tour tout au long de la chaîne de
fabrication des produits
alors les spermatozoïdes les cellules
reproductrices elles sont fabriquées là
dans les testicules mais vous avez vu ça
représente que 1% du volume total du
sperme avant de sortir ils sont mélangés
avec le fluide qui est produit au niveau
de l'épididyme dont on a déjà parlé dans
la vidéo sur le syndrome des couilles
bleus et qui se trouve ici
à ce stade là on n'a pas plus de 10 à
11% du produit fini la mixture passe
ensuite par le canal déférent justifie
hop hop hop hop hop elle fait tout le
tour et elle arrive jusqu'au niveau des
vésicules séminales qui produisent le
liquide du même nom là on tient le bon
bout on a déjà plus de 75 % du volume
total du sperme la prostate ajoute ces
sécrétions là on monte à 95% et tous à
sa patiente dans la rampe de lancement
juste ici qui s'appelle le canal et
chats culhat heures le reste est produit
ici par la glande de cooper c'est le
fameux liquide près jacut lattois
rappelait aussi l'équipe trek séminal il
va être attrapé au passage et l'huile a
déjà pris un peu d'avancé fait parce que
le liquide pressé meena lee sert à deux
choses faire baisser l'acidité dans
l'urètre avant l'arrivée des
spermatozoïdes
il n'aime pas trop ça quand cet incident
et il sert aussi de lubrifiants il est
sécrétée dès le début de la réaction et
il sort avant sans consciente du coup il
faut se méfier parce que hein
ok il contient pas de spermatozoïdes
mais il peut en rester dans l'urètre
d'une précédente éjaculation du coup lui
il va les amener vers la sortie
et en cas de rapport il peut y avoir ces
conditions deux des études ont montré
que le vih étaient présents deux dents
chez les personnes séropositives
donc il peut être contaminants surtout
qui sort un peu quand il le sent bon
mais les autres liquides à quoi ils
servent
le liquide présent au niveau de
l'épididyme il sert à transporter les
spermatozoïdes et à les aider à
poursuivre leur maturation
c'est une sorte de chaperon 1 les
conduits
et il les booste un peu parce que la
première fois qu'ils sortent sont pas
complètement fini les pétards le liquide
produit au niveau des vésicules
séminales lui c'est un peu le
ravitaillement
il est chargé de nourrir les
spermatozoïdes et de leur permettre de
tenir la distance parce que quand toute
la machinerie ce met en branle tout ce
petit monde pars du principe qu'on est
parti pour un road trip jusqu'à l'ovule
en réalité la star n'ont pas toujours
comme ça vous savez mais dans le doute
pour le voyage les vésicules séminales
elles ont prévu de quoi tenir le coup
elles ont prévu du fructose et
différentes substances comme des
prostaglandines et des protéines qui
sont chargés de favoriser la fécondation
est de protéger les spermatozoïdes
pendant le trajet et donc les sécrétions
prostatique elles elles contiennent des
substances qui stimule la mobilité des
spermatozoïdes et qui poursuivent leur
maturation le sperme contient aussi des
vitamines et des sels minéraux phosphore
magnésium potassium calcium zinc etc
voilà au final mais vous connaissez
peut-être je ne sais pas le cocktail il
est translucide avec une couleur
blanchâtre voir un peu jaunâtre parfois
il est très transparent parfois il est
très jaune c'est normal ça dépend juste
du dosage des différents ingrédients
alors si les rouges par contre peut y
avoir du sang de dans la forcément grave
mais ça mérite quand même d'aller en
parler o m et l'odeur alors est là ce
sont les protéines contenues dans le
sperme qui lui donne cette odeur
caractéristique même si elle peut varier
dans
toujours question de dosage comme pour
n'importe quel cocktail et au sujet du
goût il peut varier aussi pour les mêmes
raisons et aussi par rapport à
l'alimentation
il ya des aliments qui peuvent modifier
le goût du sperme
alors on vient ou en mal ça c'est juste
une question de goût justement mais on
peut quand même retenir que le café le
tabac l'alcool niveau saveur c'est pas
terrible
pareil pour les oignons l'ail les
brocolis ou les choux de bruxelles
par contre les fruits genre les
nectarines ou la mangue c'est pas mal et
aussi la menthe la camomille et le thé
vert
il ya même des petits malins qui vendent
des pilules qui donnent bon bout au
sperme
puisqu'on en est là il ya quand même un
truc dont il faut combler les une espèce
de kif très répandu autour de l'aspect
remous s'agit du latin sperme à la
semence donc le sperme et du grec falgos
manger ok pour ce combat fait de langue
morte avaler la boue l'avènement du coup
on raconte énormément de choses sur les
bienfaits du sperme en tant que
complément alimentaire
on va pas faire le tour de tout ce qui
se raconte non plus mais quand même pour
résumer oui le sperme c'est plein de
bonnes choses pour seulement 15 à 30
calories par éjaculats c'est-à-dire un
ou deux apéritifs
voire un peu moins donc effectivement ça
fait pas grossir
mais attention ça fait pas maigrir non
plus non ça c'est faux ah et on lit
aussi un peu partout qu'un évacue la aux
jeunes bien ce mot on évacue la
contiendrait autant de protéines 15 9
on lit ça partout ce sans vraiment
savoir d'où ça vient et en réalité c'est
probablement beaucoup moins et au sujet
des éléments qui composent le sperme et
qui sont censés avoir mille vertus
antioxydantes ou est bon pour les
cheveux ou est bon pour la peau et
cetera et cetera en réalité faudrait
vraiment consommé quotidiennement une
grosse quantité pour que ce soit
vraiment efficace
bon si vous cherchez des produits anti
âge où je voulais prendre soin de vos
cheveux ou de votre peau pour quand même
savoir que dans le commerce ya des
produits qui ont été mis au point
exprès pour ça après si vraiment vous
êtes branché [ __ ] moi juge pas on est
tous tout
d'ailleurs c'est ça le truc au fond avec
cette histoire de sperme ou magie c'est
comme avec toutes les pratiques
sexuelles pas la peine d'aller inventer
des histoires faites le si vous en avez
envie et ne le faites pas si vous n'en
avez pas envie ou plus en et surtout
évidemment essayer pas de forcer
quelqu'un qui a pas envie de le faire
alors dernière chose avant de se quitter
il ya un autre truc que le sperme peut
contenir le vih ou tout type
d'infections sexuellement transmissibles
donc en deux mots dépistage et
protection je vous remet un petit lien
dans la description ça peut pas faire de
mal vous l'avez compris oui le sperme
c'est vachement bien mais c'est pas non
plus de l'ambroisie needler liquide à la
peine d'aller braquer une banque du
sperme
d'ailleurs on peut donner son sperme
c'est même bien le faire il ya des gens
qui ont besoin mais c'est gratuit est
pas rémunéré
la réponse à ta question du courneau
voit la dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres prenez soin de votre
sperme et de celui des êtres qui vous
sont chers
mettez vous bien et surtout porté ville
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est tous tombés
faire
[Musique]